Does AM Health actually improve outcomes or lower costs?
A 2015 article, in the Journal of Medical Internet Research,
focused on AM Health as a tool to increase adherence in crying disease management.
The authors found 107 papers that met their criteria.
Of these, 41 more randomized clinical trials that measured the effects of
AM Health on disease specific clinical outcomes in conditions such as diabetes,
or chronic cardiovascular, or lung diseases.
16 of these studies,
around 40% reported significant improvements.
Based on this, the authors say quote,
"There is potential for AM Health tools to better
facilitate adherence to chronic disease management,
but the evidence supporting its current effectiveness is mixed."
You can see here,
in this graphic from that article that text messaging,
SMS, was the most commonly used tool in the primary platform.
It can facilitate patient provider communication,
medication reminders, and data collection and exchange,
on disease specific measurements.
As well as deliver patient education and motivation.
It has the advantage you're working on virtually all cell phones.
This can be particularly important in developing countries where
lower cost phones may be more common.
The next most common technology with smartphone apps,
often use to help diabetes patients remember to check symptoms,
maintain a food diary,
or connect to educators in real-time.
Next, where standalone wireless or Bluetooth compatible devices are those such as
a blood glucose meter that are connected to a phone for
automatic transfer of data for review by a healthcare provider.
In some systems, measurements that fall outside of the target range, trigger alerts.
Another issue is AM Health data quality.
A study in December,
2016 issue of the respected journal Health Affairs,
evaluated 137 patient facing AM Health apps that were highly rated by consumers,
and recommended by experts,
and that targeted high-need,
high-cost populations based on a long list of medical conditions.
The authors found that quote,
"Consumers ratings were poor indications of apps clinical utility or usability,
and that most apps did not respond appropriately
when a user entered potentially dangerous health information."
End quote. They further found that, quote,
"very few apps focused on providing guidance based on
user entered information or support through social networks,
or on rewarding behavior change.
Functionality is likely to be useful to relatively more engaged patients."
The authors also note that quote,
"data privacy and security will continue to be
major concerns in the dissemination of AM Health apps."
End quote. This is an interesting,
but unfortunately not yet openly available study.
Another aspect of AM Health data quality is
the ability of patients to properly operate in-home devices.
They may incorrectly wear blood pressure cuffs.
Patients may hold an item,
steadying themselves against a wall or other object,
or wear substantially different clothing as they weigh themselves.
These issues clearly point to the need for careful training,
and devices that to the extent possible,
can detect such situations and coax patients to use proper technique.